all right
adriana adriana where'd you grow up
where are you from originally
long beach long beach and uh tell me
about your family you had both your
parents when you were a kid
my dad wasn't around um he
he basically left my mom when she was
pregnant with me
and i grew up with my parents my
grandparents
so your grandparents raised you muslim
yes and how was your childhood
my childhood um i i was living a good
childhood with my grandparents
my mom she was working all the time and
when i hit 16 that's when i moved back
up from northern california to southern
california back to long beach
and just stay with my mom and she would
always be partying and [ __ ] like that
and i would be home by myself she was
drunk
all the time so i just ended up you know
going
out doing my thing hanging out with like
guys that were like
20 older than me and um and you were old
i was 16 16. yeah
and um she had a drinking problem and
when she met my my stepdad now my
my her new husband they would always
fight
and they would get abusive and i
wouldn't
want to be home i ended up getting
pregnant
at 18. i had my daughter when i was 19.
well almost 19 oh a week before my
19th birthday and
i ended up you know giving her up for
adoption
and my baby daddy uh
he wasn't wanting to do nothing with the
baby
until i told him i was giving her up for
adoption and she told
he told me that he was gonna fight for
her
uh i had the baby and i chosen
i chose an open adoption and right
before
he right before the deadline
for the adoption to be finalized
he um he
signed over his he signed over um saying
that he won the fight for the custody so
he ended up winning custody i ended up
going back um
living with my mom because i got
when i got pregnant i left with my
grandparents
back to my grandparents because my mom
didn't want anything to do with me
so um i went back to my grandparents
and my baby daddy got full custody
and i i didn't want to be
back at my mom's house but i had no
choice so
and it got so bad to the point where i
ended up leaving again
and i met some guy on that
introduced me to crystal and i ended up
getting hooked on that um
and as time went by
my addiction got bad and
it made me not be around my daughter it
made me just
not want to do nothing with my family i
ended up
on schedule and
i just trying to do anything possible to
make money
um i had gotten into a car accident
uh last about a year ago
going on a year next year
last year in may and i flew out the car
and i felt i fell asleep and the guy who
was driving
fell asleep too behind the wheel and
next thing you know
i uh i'm on i'm on the ground
and i'm waking up and i'm asking the guy
can you put me back in the car
like can you stop screaming he said the
car was flipped over
and i was so out of it that i asked him
huh uh can you put me back in the car
and then
he said no the cars flipped over i'm
like really
and i fell back asleep um
that around that time i didn't know i
got into a car accident
i went when i went to the hospital
the nurse when i woke back up the nurse
told me i got to a car accident
and i was like i was shocked i was like
what and the guy
went to jail he waited for the ambulance
to come get me
and um he walked to
the trailer park or the trailer park it
was the middle of the desert
and the trailer park was about a mile or
two away
and there was nothing around so he
walked to go get help
and beat the ambulance back
and i had died
and i see my grandpa that passed away a
couple years before that
and i seen his dad and they told me that
you have no you you still have time on
this
you still have things you get not to be
uh to be
you got things to be done still
and the next thing you know i wake up
and i'm the guy screaming and
i'm just like i'm cold can put me back
in the car
and it was crazy so you feel like you
died
yeah i i did die i died and i came back
god gave me another chance to live on
this planet
so um i'm just trying to find my purpose
how was death how deaf
um it was kind of it was
it was kind of cool not kind of cool but
like you think it's a dream when you die
you don't think it's real like you just
think it's a dream like how long how
long did this last you think
um lasted like maybe like 10
around 15 minutes um
and how i knew that it was
that i had died because this little girl
got into this little boy got round over
like uh probably like a mile from where
i was at
and i've seen on the news um on the
um the facebook news that
there was a girl that got hit a baby
that got hit with uh by a hit-and-run
driver
that didn't know that they hit something
and they could have just kept going
and when i died i seen this little girl
going into like you know going into the
um
going to like uh meeting these two
people
and i couldn't see the people i'm i
i just felt them and i just knew that
like
i just knew that it was like
it was just it was it was me it was it
was cool it was cool
the little girl she went up and i seen
she had like the most beautiful wings
ever and she went up with the two people
that
uh that welcomed her and i sat there and
it was like and i was thinking to myself
like
why can't i go i felt kind of like sad a
little bit
and i see my grandpa and i looked at him
and i could tell it was my grandpa
because it was like a younger version of
him
and he just looked at me and then i
heard the voice say
you've still got things to be done you
need to go back
so you're you're now in hell here on
skid row
so i'm back back over here on skid row
and um
and enough yeah how long you've been
here um
two years two years yeah and what is
your drug now still chris
crystal and how are you supporting
yourself now
um i get a money check and then
i'll be working i'll be hustling getting
money
trading um i'll be doing anything
possible yeah yeah including
doing what a lot of the girls will do
for money yeah dating guys and stuff
like that
yeah yeah has that been dangerous for
you
um yeah i got into a couple of scenarios
in my life before i got into one certain
area where i got locked in the trunk
of a car and i was trying to get out and
the guy was not letting me out he told
me to walk
and i told him i wasn't going to walk i
didn't want to walk
the streets and he said well if you
don't
if you don't walk then i'm going to beat
your ass
because you owe me some money and i was
like okay
so i lied i
he dropped me off i went the other way
and he found me locked me in the trunk
and
then he told me well we're going to try
this again
this time he had a [ __ ] walk with me so
that was kind of i got away
eventually and um
yeah i didn't [ __ ] with him ever since
but i got myself in a couple of
scenarios but i'm smart now i don't
i i was dumb back then
i was are you more careful now with guys
that will pick you up
yeah what have you learned
what have i learned i mean like or what
what kind of guy will you not get in a
car with
i wouldn't get i mean i i wouldn't get
in the car with just any guy
i mean if i knew him um
i probably will [ __ ] with him but if i
don't know him and he's like
being a stalkerish i won't i will i
would just look at him and just walk
away
do you have any contact with your mom
still yeah she um she's really made
my my baby now she ended up
wanting you know her my mom's her and
her
my stepdad are raising my kid oh they
are
yeah so do you see your daughter
sometimes now
yeah uh next week is her birthday
so she'll be eight years old i'm an
eight-year-old little girl
and what keeps you from getting your
life together and going back you think
i'm trying to get my life together
honestly i'm trying to
save it for a place i mean it's kind of
hard with the
with the durian and it being so high and
um but i'm almost there
tell me about quitting crystal meth does
that seem like a possibility for you
yeah um it really is because i want to
be more of a mom to my kid
i want to be i want to live like this
like i've been doing this way too long
and i wake up and i'm
and i'm like 27 years old i'm still
young i could i could change my life
absolutely yeah and um
when i see other people out here that
are like older and [ __ ] like that it
just makes me like i don't want to be
like that when i'm
you know and it's true what they say
it's harder when you get older
so i need to get my [ __ ] and get it
trying to be serious about my [ __ ] now
because i wasn't serious before
i was just [ __ ] bullshitting playing
around saying i was
you know i'm getting on my [ __ ] i didn't
get on my [ __ ] and
now i'm like damn i'm like 27 years old
and i see like all my other
friends that they got their [ __ ]
together
and it makes me like like i need to get
my [ __ ] together
because is there anything about the way
you were brought up you think that maybe
um took you down this path i think see
my mom
you know like getting drunk and always
partying and [ __ ] like that
um it kind of like pushed me to
you know not be home and not be you know
go out me going out till three in the
morning
and then having to go to school as a
junior in high school at seven o'clock
and um
the last two years of my high school i
didn't go to school
i mean i went to school but i didn't go
to my classes
so it was like i was ditching in school
which was kind of stupid because like if
i'm
if i'm not even going to go to school at
all i mean going to my classes why
be in school how far did you go in
school
i did that four years but i failed to
two years
so i would have to take another two
years of school
and how do you think your life on the
streets has changed you
um it made me realize a lot of
real [ __ ] be uh like
if you don't get up get your ass up and
work and
you know do something to make get some
money really you ain't gonna have
nothing
and that's where like not just people
out in the street that's from for like
everybody
if you don't get you if you don't get up
and get a job or like do something with
yourself
you ain't gonna be like how are you
gonna eat i'm gonna survive
like it's and where are you staying now
right now i'm in i'm staying in my car
so you have a car yeah i have a car
it's better than a tent i guess right
yeah
i've stayed in tents before first time
i've stayed in the tent
i was just like oh my god this [ __ ] is
crazy
like i'm in a tent i've never lived like
that before
so i've taken myself way way way down
is this is this the lowest point of your
life right now yeah yeah
i was brought up with everything and
anything you could think about
anything i wanted i had it my
grandparents scored me
and i just like
when my grandpa passed away um
it [ __ ] me up because he was like my
dad
so i distanced myself from my family a
lot
and my family and i
aren't close as we used to be i missed
out on so many things in my family just
because
of how when my grandpa died it killed me
like it made me so numb i didn't even
know when the funeral was
i just lost track of time i lost track
of everything
so what emotions do you deal with now
um just kind of
kind of anxiety anxiety and about
about trying to hurry up and trying to
get my [ __ ] together
because i wasted so much time already
and my daughter you know she'd be um
she didn't understand anymore so it's
like
um over here she's wondering why my mom
is not around
does she ask you um
no not really my mom i think my mommy
telling her like
your mom's not around because she's
doing other things
i think at this point my my dog she's
smart she's smart like
she got like her little attitude she's
smart
um i don't know how my daughter looks at
me
really and i think that's what what
makes me more
kind of um kind of sad
in a way because i don't know how my
daughter looks at me
she calls she calls me mommy
but she know she she knows that
she feels like her mom is my grandma i
mean my mom my mom
my mom is her mom
so i don't think she really understands
like the meaning of a mom
like the deaf like i think she's
confused in a way
because she calls me mom but she calls
she
she my my my mom is one of her moms so
she feels
more like okay my mom is
my mommy is
not really my mom yeah i'm sure she's
confused
yeah and that's what kind of makes me
upset and
kind of kills me is crystal meth hard to
stop using
um
a little bit i mean i have i have my
days where i'll be sober
but as soon as i see somebody that's got
a pipe
i'm like i i don't think about it i just
be like hey i'm
like let's get high now
so it's kind of it's hard
i know i can do it it just i'm dealing
with like a whole lot of
whole lot of other things so sometimes i
just
give up
so i'm trying to get my life together
what emotions does being separate from
your child
bring up um
the fear um of her
not wanting to
to like the fear not of her not wanting
to
anything to do with me um
because i haven't really been around
like
as much as i used to be around
and um so it's kind of
it's kind of hard because i don't want
her growing up and
how and have her feel like what i felt
for my mom
when i was growing up and just not
just feeling like like she didn't know
me yeah like she sees me she knows me
but
she don't know me as you know her mom
and i feel kind of
like i've i pray that
i get another chance you know i've been
a mom
you know i pray that i get another baby
when i get pregnant by a good man
and i can have another baby and do it
all over again
but the last time i got pregnant
i got my tube bursted
and i didn't know i was pregnant and so
when i did
emergency surgery they found a baby that
was i
think like 14 weeks inside me
they took out my tube they took out the
baby and
now i have like 40 chance of being
pregnant again
so my lifestyle has really like just
made me like
go down bad but you have a child
i have a child you could be with her
right now yeah
the only problem is my mom she
she'd still be doing her drinking my
stepdad does her drink
uh the drinking and i can't deal with
that [ __ ] i can't deal with him always
talking [ __ ] to me talking putting holes
in my walls because they're fighting
and then the next day they're good and
then the following day they're at it
again
like who wants to be around that yeah
did you feel like you were loved as a
child by your parents
your mom or your grandparents about my
grandparents yeah my mom yes
but my mom had a drinking problem and
she just couldn't see what
what the lifestyle she was living and
the things she was doing was
affecting me if i didn't have to feel
like i couldn't come home
and the feeling of not wanting to be
home
i don't think i would have ever been
drugged i don't think i've ever would
have met that guy who introduced me to
crystal
and next thing you know i'm like
doing crystal i don't don't even know
what the [ __ ] the uh
the the high was like until
i'm like up for days and i don't know
what the [ __ ] i'm doing and it was like
i had a cousin that overdosed on drugs
when he was 17
and i was 14 years old so
when when he died
i it took it took me to the point where
i didn't want to do drugs
i thought drug addicts were disgusting i
never thought i would be a drug addict
or addicted to
and having gone through all this what's
the most important lesson you've learned
in your life
the most important lesson i learned is
life itself is a lesson
everything you go through is for a
reason but at the same time
you gotta you gotta choose the right you
know
the right past week because when i got
into that car accident
it made me really it made me think that
like
you know after i woke up and i you know
i woke up
and i got to where i got in the car
accident it made me realize like
death is you can death is real
and when you die you're gonna you're
gonna be welcomed by
by these figures
and you're either gonna go to hell or
you're gonna go to heaven
or you might get it you might get
another chance and be lucky like me and
get told that you're gonna go
you gotta go back
i never thought that i would have died
and
got toilet i had to go back
um but this is probably not the life
that you were supposed to come back to
no i was kind of sad that i didn't get
to go back with my grandpa
and that little girl but let me tell you
that little girl was so happy
she was so happy it made me made me
smile
and i thought it was all a dream at
first i didn't know i died when i died
i just put the pieces together and i
just felt it in my heart like
oh my god like i'm because who survives
an
accident the car flips over i fly out
the window
who's gonna stay asleep through all that
who's gonna like did the driver survive
yeah
he survived he woke up uh when the car
was rolling over
so he woke up i wasn't on i wasn't on
anything
uh i wasn't on no weed no sitting on no
nothing
i was knocked the [ __ ] out i didn't have
my seatbelt on
but luckily i just got a broken collar
bone
and my my finger my hand was [ __ ] up
but
and i got released from the hospital
that same day
really yeah yeah i was
really damn confused i mean
the nurse wakes me up and she goes um
yeah do you have anyone you could call
because um
you're getting released now i'm like
what happened i don't even know what to
happen
she's like well the car rolled over and
you flew out the window and
and um you got in the car accident
i'm like what i started bawling i knew i
had no pain in my body no nothing i just
felt like i just
thought later on i put pizzas together
and i remember like
seeing my seeing the guy's dad that i
got into a car accident
seen him seen his dad and i've never
seen his dad before but his
dad died but i just knew it was your dad
you just know when you die you know
what's what
you feel it you might not know you died
if you get a chance to come back again
you might not know you died
but at first but
you just you put pizza together
yeah and it it's crazy i would have i
would have thought
something like that might have changed
your behavior
yeah it did more than it has it
it changed me on how
it changed it changed me wanting to
[ __ ]
be more on my [ __ ] and stop playing
around and stop [ __ ]
thinking that life was a joke life is
just a game
all right adriana thank you so much for
sharing your story and i wish you the
best of luck i hope you get back with
your daughter
thank you i hope you put down the
crystal mat
i will thank you
you